hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be a reaction video for the Wally West
casting the flash season two had teased
him for a long time they just made it
official we don't know how he's gonna
get his powers or how they're gonna
explain where he comes from because he
will have the Wally West name he'll be
related to Iris and Joe West but they
haven't said anything about what
happened to irises mom supposedly she
doesn't have a brother
that she knows about so he could either
turn out to be like a long-lost half
brother like a child that Joe West had
with someone else and then just didn't
know about or he could be from earth-2
now we know Jay Garrick's from earth-2
so they might not double down on that
Wally West it sounds like they might go
the soap opera route doesn't that just
sound like a plot line that you would
see on the CW show the reason I like the
bastard Joe West storyline is because it
gives him a reason to be pissed off at
Joe West and it gives iris a reason to
be pissed off at him just because I you
know I feel like they have to make that
family dynamic interesting and now that
the drama with Barry has largely
subsided like they put Barry and iris on
hold like they're not gonna be
developing that storyline at all they'll
both be way too busy with other things
to deal with like their internal sexual
tension naturally something has to fill
that conflict void and mystery bastard
child is the the perfect gasoline to
throw on that flame most of you probably
know the Wally West from Geoff Johns run
the original version of the character he
got his power to the exact same way
Barry Allen got his he was visiting
Barry while he was working in his lab
and a bunch of chemicals spilled on him
and he got hit by lightning BAM he took
the ink Kid Flash and then after a
crisis on Infinite Earths he was
inspired by Barry Allen sacrificed to
take the mantle and became the flash
proper until Barry Allen came back
during rebirth then he kind of shuttled
off into obscurity till the new 52 when
they rebooted the character and give him
a completely different origin story just
completely change the character from the
ground up right now DC is doing the
exact same thing again they're they're
completely rebooting the character so
the Wally West that you meet next year
is going to be completely different from
the new 52 Wally West that's why the CW
like like the flash TV show version of
the character is gonna have a slightly
different origin story from the comic
book version of Wally West the the new
52 version I know they're both
african-american they cast an
african-american actor so naturally a
lot of people point to the new 52
version
that their version is gonna be in line
with the new version that DC is working
on but we haven't really learned a lot
about that the new comic book version
yet so I can't say much about it I think
the people behind the flash TV show
write good characters so like whatever
they end up doing I'm sure it'll be fine
and remember this is gonna be a
supporting character wally west
technically isn't a main character so
it's not like he's gonna be dominating
the screen all the time even if you
don't like the character you won't have
to sit through him every single week but
i am really curious to see which episode
he debuts in like if he just rides into
town in the first episode or if it takes
a couple weeks I'm probably butchering
his name but Kenyon Lyons Dale's the
name of the actor that they picked he's
an Aussie I saw a lot of Australian
people in the comments last week
cheering about that whenever I posted my
Vandal Savage video I'm not super
familiar with his work I skip the
divergent series but that's like the
biggest thing that he's been a part of
he the last big thing was insurgent I
think we'll actually be getting our
first proper season 2 trailer in the
next week or two maybe three weeks it'll
either premiere whenever they do their
TCA panel or it'll be whenever they
premiere vixen logically I think it'd
make more sense for them to use it to
promote the vixen premiere because I
think there's still a lot of people that
don't know about that show but they
might have enough time to shoot some
scenes with him to get into that trailer
so we can actually see Wally West on
screen because if there's anything that
they could put in that trailer that
would make people crap their pants with
excitement it would be Jay Garrick Wally
West and zoom you know supposedly that
teaser trailer they posted had some zoom
in it but I feel like they're gonna
refine that character quite a bit I feel
like what we saw is just like a
preliminary thing it almost looks like a
shadow of Barry Allen like like a
blackish suit with blue lightning you
guys can let me know like what do you
think about like a different version of
Wally West being on the TV show than
you've seen in the comics obviously he's
going to be different from the classic
version but I'm really interested to see
if they give him his powers in a twist
way on the original wally west like if
he goes to visit barry at STAR Labs and
gets struck by lightning usually when
the arrow and flash have done big comic
book characters in Wally West is a major
character they're fairly true to their
original origin story like even though a
lot of details about Barry Allen has
changed over over time when we saw Grant
Gustin
his version of Barry Allen get his
powers on TV it was very close visual
to the original origin story now
obviously the particle accelerator
explosion is like the new addition the
thing that they changed so whenever we
see Wally West for the first time just
everybody hold their breath and wait for
him to get his powers really I think
like the worst thing that they could do
would be to bring him on the show and he
already has powers there's something
that's just so spectacular about
watching a new comic book superhero get
their powers it's like watching the
universe reach down with a finger and
touch them as if it's selecting a new
champion Grant Gustin did say that that
in the first episode like as he's fixing
like the the big problem of the finale
that big black hole in the sky zoom
would appear and then who would go on to
legends of tomorrow he's gonna be the
big bad on flash season 2 but he will be
part of legends of tomorrow so even
though everyone is super bummed out
about Fantastic Four I feel like there's
still a lot to be excited about if you
guys aren't caught up on season 1 now's
the time to do that I know a lot of you
are also wondering when it's gonna drop
on Netflix usually that happens a little
bit after the DVD comes out like they
don't want to dilute DVD sales by
releasing the episodes for free on
Netflix or oh you know technically it's
not free but I believe the DVD is
dropping sometime in September so that's
probably when Netflix is gonna get all
the episodes next week is going to be
the CW TC a panel so they will be
talking about the flash and arrow if
they mention anything really cool I'll
add it to my videos that week so be sure
to subscribe to get that and if there
any other like character bonus videos
you guys want before then let me know I
feel like everyone's rushing to get the
Fantastic Four taste out of their mouth
in case you haven't seen it I did post a
non-spoilery Fantastic Four review you
can click here to watch it and you can
click here to learn all about vandal
savage's history in the comics thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow